hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to in Lucy's eyes now
I'm not to go to this basement but I
want to make you guys as paranoid as I
am right now so throughout this video
I'm gonna remind you that you haven't
checked behind you in a while and there
could be something standing by right
behind you looking at you at any given
moment when you turn your head away
that's when it looks at you and it's
right there right now just looking at
you don't turn your head okay this isn't
as bad as I thought it was gonna be it's
just like um a sewer of some sort anyway
so that's good so far so good
I'm wondering if like throughout this
game there's gonna be like there's gonna
be eyes staring at me from some obscure
location like the g-man from half-life 2
when he was just like observing you from
random locations throughout the game cuz
I imagine this game is just gonna be
douchey like that I mean this game kind
of already has been a little bit douche
eh I would not appreciate a water
monster at this juncture well I imagine
there's gonna be a fee imagine there's
gonna be a secret goody-goody back over
this way because it's not a place that I
could easily get to oddly enough it's
kind of relaxing at this moment the
sound of the babbling brook is kind of
making me feel all warm and fuzzy inside
I'm pretty sure it's gonna replace that
with cold feelings and making me seem
like I'm dead inside I'm probably gonna
make me seem like I'm dead outside -
pretty sure it likes it
okay all right okay
oh that's it okay all you couldn't have
been it
oh oh by the way don't look behind you
right now it's there right now seriously
don't look behind you okay so now I
gotta find out where to get to this
mechanism which okay oh okay okay okay
all right
oh okay
hi how's it going there oh that's dark
oh it's good no hi
oh it's gonna do the thing oh it's gonna
do the thing
oh it's gonna do the thing I was trying
to do to you but seriously it's right
behind you okay all right hello oh the
music is lovely in this area sure glad I
paid extra for the good sound system
could do I go down further or oh okay
can you stop that I really don't like
that it's not appreciated I don't mind
it or I don't like it I mind it I mind
it a lot shut up please
don't do that Oh criminy Christmas Oh
criminy Christmas Oh jiminy Christmas
okay we're okay we're okay
looks like what is that it's not a
cogwheel machine so I just need the
cogwheels all right I know your games
amnesia I know how you work
okay so there's probably probably some
more around here somewhere
all right cool cool cool cool got it got
it got it okay here we go
gotta get it out again I gotta go go go
oh boy oh boy I love my life
all right come on come I come I don't
let that out on me let that out all ye
okay do I just need the three is that
all I need all right here we go
kachunk do I run away do I run away oh
do the thing oh yeah do you think oh I
got you now now now now oh oh
Oh
I don't think that's uh I don't think a
more appropriate definition of nervous
laughter has ever been observed I'm
seriously it's weird like I just I have
no other coping mechanism besides
laughing oh man this game is flippin
terrifying like dan don't do that I'm
out I'm out baby I'm Audi I'm Audi I'm
out here 9000 a now do do-do-do do-do
depot okay
all right cool all right don't be afraid
oh oh why do I have a cut on my hand now
oh man okay oh boy
all right okay I need like a breather
god damn uh seriously don't look mind
you though it's kind of right there okay
moving forward damn seriously I haven't
been like out of just like purely
amnesia like I haven't been spooked a
long time I mean I've been startled like
I've been jump scared oh man no not why
why was the building why was the
building shaky I actually had to turn I
had to turn down the volume of the game
cuz it was too loud who's too loud in my
ears mmm okay alright huh okay moving
forward I'm fine I'm fine but you may
not be fine
cuz it's looking at you right now you
can see it out of the corner of your
eyes last time no Elizabeth it's
impossible you have any real sense about
how much energy I have to spend
maintaining this colossal stronghold are
you mad I got me a harder now
okay so that's my a civil discussion
tone me being mr. Richard Dickman I just
love my wife so much and love my castle
even more that I'm going to die horribly
I see why I deserve this why do I the
player deserve this
why do I have to come through this all
right
oh good
our winery we're going water level where
the water monsters gonna come in okay
okay okay okay
Oh more cogs okay wait do I need to do
that is that a requirement okay
okay what do I do
oh okay bye okay don't do that don't do
that here
yeah that looked like a new thing to I
mean it's it's really impressive the
amount of work that went into this mod I
mean considering all the custom
animation some of the custom art though
was in the air like that was a different
new monster it's all good it's all good
so it's good it's good I love it I love
it I love this I love doing this it's my
favorite thing to do okay all right all
right okay okay so uh again who is Lucy
who is Lucy that's that's the big
question here who's okay is that instant
death steam
god damn it damn it damn it [ __ ] that
sucks okay but I'm okay I'm okay
hopefully that's gonna stop some of the
monsters from getting after me okay this
looks familiar from Justine
damn it damn it can never work the door
won't open until I lower the water level
in the room behind it okay okay okay all
right okay okay how many times have I
said okay in the past few minutes oh oh
no oh no no oh no no no no
no oh no oh no no oh boy some moving
some moving some moving who's that was
that moving for that moment I saw the
movin oh sorry move it oh they saw me
over
oh don't look no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no what are you whoa what are you a
guy get away wow that's a weird
get away do it do it do it
my throw barrel is half you go like that
oh [ __ ] oh oh you didn't like that okay
good enough
oh I can't see anything hi how's it
going okay cool
shits fudge sickle ass crack oh I'm not
doing anything right
oh no I'm doing I don't know one oh I
don't know
just finish it finish it
oh okay be quiet he has no eyes that
wouldn't be a problem if I wasn't
splish-splash in oh you suck [ __ ] okay
okay so now that I know that I'm gonna
disturb him yeah yeah that did it give
that won't move is even there anymore
you might not be there anymore well I
might have gotten close I might have
actually kind of done it okay I don't
think he's here anymore
I don't think he's here
okay all right okay all right okay
okay all right all right okay all right
grabbing a good time we're having fun
here we're having a great time he's
right behind you
don't turn around seriously please so
he's gonna get ya oh man we're having
fun okay okay okay come on come on what
what come on come on come on come on
come on please come on
oh he's gonna give me
okay I need a break I need a break I
need a break so it's all the time I have
for this part it's all the hard I have
for this part goddamn goddamn goddamn
exhaustible oh man I haven't been on
this on edge in a long time this is a
phonetic this is a fantastic amnesia
custom story so anyway thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the annotation for other cool Emmys
cousin stories that I've done in the
past
don't turn around he's literally right
behind you all this time not looking at
him just let him get closer to you what
were you thinking so thank you everybody
so much for watching I hope you survive
the night and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye I'm wrong
they're just everywhere here's the
bridge wait oh did I cross this bridge
the same branch wait a minute
Oh huh locked on target
truck truck